えっと で あの おそらく百六十四あたりだと思いますけど
まあ一応あの このポイントは百六十二ページの三十二番目のこのチュッタパティサンディックマというところから始まりますので
まあこれから あの  この辺は少々触れたでしょうと思いますけど
人のあの死とまた生まれというこの働きは
まあどのようになるかっていう説明なんですね
それで まず人が まあ人と言ったら生命の死のことなんですけど
なんで死ぬかと で 生きてるということは
この心と体のエネルギーの流れですから
やっぱりずっとエネルギーを補っておかないと
もう切れちゃうんですね
で 我々体のことはよく知ってるんだから
まあずっと体に食べ物と酸素とかね
水とかね そういうものをずっと与えておかないと体がすぐ壊れてしまうんです
ですから 体のことはいくらかわかってるんです
毎日食べなくちゃいけないし
で 本当はまあ瞬間瞬間
体の細胞にはいつでも栄養必要なんです
まあ体の中でね まあそういう栄養の倉庫ができているんだからね
我々はずっと食べっぱなしではありませんだけどね
まあいくらか食べたら
まあそれを溜まって まあある時間ずっとそれ使ってて
それでまた食べなくちゃいけないし
水の場合も同じで 水を飲んだら一旦体に入って
それどんどん体から消えていっちゃったら
また水を入れてあげないといけないし
そういうふうに体を維持するためには
ずっと体に物質的なエネルギーを与えてないと体が壊れちゃう
で 流れるものだから変化していくものだから
まあそうなるんですね
で で 心もだいたい同じことで
心にもエネルギーはないと
まあ壊れてしまうんですが
心の場合だけは少々法則が違いまして
心に必要なのはもうなんとか刺激というものなんですね
一つの心がなくなっちゃうと
まあそれで新しい心がその代わりに生まれるんです
ですから 心の場合はこの維持するという意味がないんです
瞬間で死ぬんです ですから
何とかして心を支えてずっと持っていこうと思ったっても
それは無理なんですね
体は何とかすることはできますけど
心は何とかすることできないんです
で 心はまあ瞬時に死んじゃうんです
現れたらすぐ死ぬと で
死んじゃったら まあその死んだ心の代わりに
まあ瞬間に新しい心が生まれる
生まれてもそれまたすぐ瞬時に死ぬんですね
死んだらまたその代わりに新しい心が生まれるんですね
ですから 体より心のところはちょっと違うんですね
で ちょっと何か栄養を与えたんだからといって
一秒間でも心は同じ状態でも保つっていうことはできないんです
だからそういう法則だからね
まあどういう法則かというと
まあ心というものは瞬間現れて
寿命は瞬間だけであって
現れたらすぐ消えて死んでしまっちゃう
消えたらまたその代わりに新しい心が生まれる
で 生まれてもそれすぐ瞬時に消えちゃうし
またその代わりに新しい心が生まれちゃうんですね
で それは一つの体の中でずっと起きていく出来事なんですね
ですから 体という物体の中に
この強烈な速さで心という流れが流れていっちゃうんですね
で 心っていうのは認識機能ですから
見る心と聞く心は違うんですね
体で感じる時の心はまた違うものですね
性質的にはすごく違うんです
考える時の心も この考えるものによって変わっていくんですね
だから人間にはいつでも同じ心はあるわけじゃないんです
瞬間瞬間 我々は何を考えるかということによって
その時に生まれる心は変わるんですね
その膨大に心が変わるんだから
これ勉強できないので
まあどれぐらい種類に分けられますかと心が
といえば この八十九種類ぐらいに分けられると
で その中でも一般の人々に現れるのはこの不善十二
まあいわゆる五十四の欲蓋心なんですね
五十四の欲蓋心の中でも疑疑捨心は生まれません
一般の人には 有捨心は阿羅漢にだけ生まれるんだからね
そこで有捨心八と笑喜心という笑う心がありまして
それも阿羅漢にだけ生まれる心
そのここのつを抜けなくちゃいけないんですね
そうすると  四十五種類の
四十五か四十六かな 四十五ですね
まあ四十五種類の心が
一般の人の体の中で回転しているんです
で それだったら分かりやすいんだけど
またかえってそこなかなか分かりにくいところがあるんですね
例えば欲の心があるとする
美しいバラの花を見ると綺麗だから綺麗という感覚が生まれる
綺麗という感覚は欲の心なんですね
そこで じゃあそのバラの花を見るたびに同じ心が生まれるかというと
そうじゃないんですね
やっぱりその見るたびに欲の心が生まれるのかもしれませんだけど
それ中でもいろいろ変わりがあるんですね
全く同じ心が生まれるということでもないんです
そういうきめ細かい心は分析できませんだからね
例えば一回目見ると生まれる楽しみと
二回目見ると生まれる楽しみが変わるんですね
どのように変わるかと言ったっても
それはわからないんですね
で 二回目見ると まあ見たんだから面白くないという人もいるし
もっと明確に見る人もいるしね
二回目だから明確に見て
いややっぱり綺麗でしたと
そうすると ある人にとっては二回見ると欲
もっと強い欲の心が生まれるし
もう一人の人には弱い欲の心が生まれるし
ですから 同じものでも見るたびにどのように心が変わっていくかということは
なかなか難しいことで
理解しにくいことで 理解する必要もないんですね
心のそのような働きだけは人間には理解できないんだと考える必要もないんだと
そんなこと考えちゃったら狂ってしまっちゃいますよというのは
お釈迦様の言葉なんですね
だからまあ一旦わかりやすく
そういういくつかの心に分けていて
そういう心がどっちが生まれるんだと
で それで体の中で瞬間瞬間心が生まれて消えて死んで
また新しい心が生まれて
それ死んでしまって また新しい心が生まれる
それで心がある 認識するために生まれるものだから
その時その時自分の仕事をして死んじゃうんです
見る見る必要がある時
目に物質触れた時はもうそれ認識しなくちゃいけない
それでチャックヴィンヤーナという心が生まれる
チャックヴィンヤーナ眼識ですね
眼識生まれたら眼識の仕事はこの目に触れた物質を認識する
ただそれだけ それでその心は仕事終わったんだから死んでしまっちゃう
そこで一つの心が死ぬと次の心が生まれるんだから
次の心が前の心何やったんですかということによって影響を受けるんですね
ですから前の心 前眼識という心が生まれたんだから
それ死んじゃったんだから
次の心がこの前の心を受けた情報を受けるんですね
ですから 見たんだよという認識だけ眼識が作りますけど
その情報を次の心がそれを受ける
だからサンパティッチョナというんです
受心と それで受心の仕事は受けることだけ
で それでその心が死んじゃうんですね
それで次の心でいくらかのこの分け方がするんですね
いいものか悪いものかというぐらいはっきりした分け方ではないんだけど
まあなんとかいいか悪いか
なんとかには分けられるような働きがあって
次の心が生まれて その心が死んでしまっちゃう
それで次にこの固定概念の心が生まれちゃうんですね
あ あれはもうこういうものやと確定心が生まれちゃうんですね
で 確定心が生まれたら
それ確定することだけなんです
仕事は それで死んでしまっちゃうんです
次にこの意識がまた回転しちゃうんですね
確定したものについて感情の流れが流れちゃうんですね
7つの流れ 心が回転して
属行心といって もう 7回回転しちゃうんですね
そこにその 7回回転すると感情の回転だから
そこは善行為になるか悪行為になるかという善悪がそこで生まれるんですね
そのように瞬間瞬間心が生まれて消えていっちゃうし
そのその心には一つの仕事しかないし
その仕事をしてその心がそこで消えてしまう
まあそういうふうな心の働きですから
まあ一つの仕事といっても
心がする仕事を 14種類に分けてますからね
アビダンマ的に理解すればそんな難しいことじゃないんだけど
14種類の心働きが functions がありますから
そのどちらかする そういうのはもう前の過去の勉強でまあ一応やっておりましたから
ですから 私たちは死ぬということはどういうことかと
これ仏教で言う死ぬことと
俗世間で言う死ぬということは
まあある程度で変わっている可能性はありますね
一般的にアビダンマの立場から見れば
まあ体はよく分かりやすいことで
体はまあ維持できるんです
ご飯をあげたり いろんなことをしたり
エネルギーをずっとあげちゃうと
体が流れて変化していくんだけど
まあある程度その形を維持していることはできるんです
で まあ体もやっぱりエネルギー必要ですから
入れてエネルギー切れて死んでしまっちゃいますから
新しいエネルギーを入れて
またそれでゆっくりと新しい体が出来上がっちゃいますけど
その中で心っていうのはもっと強烈な速さで死んでいっちゃうんですね
死んでいくというよりは
死んで新しい心が生まれる
死んで新しい心が生まれるという働きがやってるんです
で 心にはこの一つの心が
死ぬと何で新しい心が生まれるんですかと
まあそちら まあ死ぬこと自体が新しい心が生まれることの原因になるんですね
一つのエネルギーが消えちゃったら
その代わりにまた似ているエネルギーは再現する
それで心生まれるためにはもう何とか刺激があればいいんですね
例えば なんで人間がものを見たり聞いたり考えたりしますかというしますかというと
心に刺激を与えるために
新しい思考を作るために
何か感動的な何か情報やら何かあれば
それで人間はそれによってすっごい心を回転させてもらっちゃうんですね
それで輪廻を逃すことができるんですね
そうでないと心が済まなくなってしまっちゃうんですね
済まなくなっても死ぬわけはないんだけど
とにかくいろんな情報
いろんな刺激を心に与えてあげて
それで強烈に心を回転させて回転させているのは人々の生き方なんです
で 心にはこの外から激しい形やら音やらね
ものすごい美味しい食べ物やら
そういう強烈な刺激なくても心っていうのは自己回転するんですね
例えばたった一つのことあれば
それを頭に入れておいて
思い思いがあって 何か頭にちょっとしたことを思い思いが入れておく
するとそれをまたまたまたまた繰り返して繰り返して 年間でも考えることはできるんですね
ほんのわずかなことでもいいんです
そういうことで いとも簡単に心がもう死んでもまた生まれるんで
生まれて回転するんですね
どんなご飯みたいな 食べ物みたいな
コーヒー紅茶みたいな
かなり重いものはあげなくても構いません
ほんのわずかなことでいいんです
それでも百年でも年 年でも回転できるんです
年間回転できないのは体がその前に壊れてしまっちゃいますからね
そういうふうに心が働いて回転している
ですから 死ぬということはどういうことかと
俗世間で死ぬというのは体が壊れること
でお釈迦様も死ぬということを定義するときは
カレーブラッサニッケポウ
このカレーブラっていうのは死体遺体という意味でね
もう体にいつでもそういう死体に使う言葉使ってるんです
この物体ね 体体というこの物体を捨てる
置いておく だからこの体という物体を捨てることが死ぬというんですね
誰に捨てられるかというと
心に捨てられるんですね
体を それで一般的には死という
厳密に言えば 仏教では死ということはなかなか定義難しいんです
でも一旦体を捨てちゃえば
もうその体はもう腐って土に戻ってしまっちゃうんです
そちらには私がとこういう概念もないし
見たり聞いたり考えたりする働きはもう全く消えてしまって
その人のアイデンティティ
パーソナリティ 自我 自我というのはその物体にはなくなっちゃうんですね
まあそれでそういうことには
まあ一時的な死ということを言うんですね
でも心というのは法則が自分には私たち知ってるんだから止まれないんですね
止まらなくて回転しているんですね
ここで心が止まったということは言うことはできないんですね
だから法則だから 今心止まることはできますかと
考えることは止まりますかと
止まりません たとえ瞑想したっても
心の流れが止まりません
ですから 心には止まらない法則がある
その法則はとても簡単
死ぬことだけ原因なんですね
心が死んだら新しい心が生まれるという法則
そこで瞬時に死ぬ それを瞬時に生まれる
だから死ぬ心と生まれる心は別々なものということは
ものすごく仏教で言いたいんですね
同じものじゃないんだと
同じ心生まれるんだったら
もう大変問題なんですね
そうすると人に考えることもできないし
ものを見ることもできないんですね
ずっと心全く同じだから
何見ようか 聞こうか 食べようか
もう変わらないんですね
ということは見えない
聞こえないことなんですね
そういうことは生きてないということなんです
ですから 同じ心続くということはまるっきりない
目を開けたらものを見るということは
新しい心が生まれたということ
音が入ったらそこで新しい心が生まれているんですね
体が痛みを感じたったら
すぐそこに違う心が生まれているんですね
痛みを感じる心と車の音を聞く心は全く違うものなんですね
そういうふうな感じで
心がもう一死んじゃったら違う心が生まれる
違う心は違う働きをする
そこで人間が同じものだというのは概念だけであって
妄想概念なんですね だから実体としては同じものではないんです
だから真珠のネックレスはネックレスで見れば一つで見えるのであって
本当は真珠 1個1個全く別なものなんですね
で そこで法則あるわけじゃない
この真珠の次に必ずしもこの真珠つけなくちゃいけないということはないんです
それなりに入れ替えても構いませんし
例えば真ん中に大きな真珠が入っているんだからといって
だってもそれを他のところにいたって
また別に同じネックレスになっちゃいますしね
真ん中小さな真珠入れて
両側大きな真珠玉を入れたって
それはまたネックレスであるし
あるいは大きな真珠と小さな真珠
大きな真珠と小さな真珠というふうに五灯でつなげたっても
それまた真珠のネックレスになっちゃうし
で これ糸でつなげてね
考えちゃうとネックレスになるんであって
糸なんかなければそこに全く別々な真珠なんですね
心にも糸でつなげるということはないんですから
別々な心なんですね ということで
我々は人間というのは瞬間瞬間本当は死ぬんです
この瞬間瞬間死ぬことはなかなか人間認めない
この身体の影響で それで体捨てられる瞬間
心に捨てられる瞬間が
我々は死というんですね
そこで死ぬことは 4つに分けてアユッケ
カンナッケ ウベヤッケ
ウペッチェデカという 4つに分けているんですね
寿命が消えたら死ぬんだと
寿命というのは 結局この体がこの形をどれぐらい
何年か 何年間か持てるかということなんですね
で それもやっぱり心で維持されますから
寿命っていうのは複雑なもので
で ここで生まれた時の心にはすごいエネルギーがあると
寿命 エネルギーがありまして
維持する物質の面倒を見ることはできるんですね
それで長生きできたりしますし
で 体自体にもまた寿命があるんですね
それだけは分かりやすいしね
そのその生命の細胞には寿命というものがあります
で 犬の寿命っていうのは 15年
20年で終わってしまっちゃうし
どう頑張ってもそれ伸ばすっていうことはできないので
その細胞は壊れて老化していく
また  1週間ぐらいで終われる細胞を持ってる体もあるし
それで寿命っていうのは体にもあります
心にもあります で 心にもあるんですけど
大体体のことをメインに考えて
寿命が終わったら体を捨てられちゃうんです
その体はもう使い物にならないんだと
車を買ったら五 六年でもう寿命ですから
それで買い替えになっちゃうんですね
そういうふうなことで心捨てられる
それは死と呼ぶし それからカンマ
カンマっていうのは業であってね
心が過去の業のエネルギーで現れましたからね
生まれる時は そこでその業のエネルギーが消えちゃったら
心にその体に住むことはできなくなっちゃうんですね
だから 業の結果を体として受けるんですね
例えば美しいものを 見る業がついてるんだと
美しいものを見られる
美味しいものを食べられる
業がついていると体がなければ見られないんですね
それで体にあるこの見られる能力
味わえる能力 聞こえる能力などは
聴覚などはこの業によって決められるんですね
業が終わってくると その人に聞く能力
聞いて味わう業がないし
舌で味わう業もないし
目で見て楽しむ業もないんだから
その機能が衰えていっちゃうんです
機能しなくなっちゃうんですね
目も耳も鼻も全部 機能しなくなっちゃうと
ということは 業が終わっているということなんですね
で 業が終わっていくと
もう体の機能がどんどん機能しなくなる
この体が機能しないと
心には刺激がなくなっちゃうんですね
少なくなっちゃう それで心に体を捨てられちゃう
業が消えたという 四番目っていうのは突然の事故なんですね
まあ業の力があっても
体が元気であっても 寿命があっても
あのシステム壊れちゃったらね
首を引いてしまっちゃえば
まあどうしようもない
繋げませんし またね それでまた死んでしまっちゃう
そういう四つの死に方あるんです
そこで 死ぬ瞬間で心はいつでもどんな影響でも受けますから
死ぬ瞬間で何が起こるかというと
体を捨てられる瞬間なんですね
体捨てられる瞬間だから心が体のことを気にしない
我々は引っ越しするときは一つの家を捨てて他の家に行くでしょうに
その時人の考え方はどのようにあるんですかね
今まで住んでた部屋についてすごい執着がありますかね
全くないでしょう いつでも頭にいっぱいあるのは荷物のことか
新しい住まいのことか
どっちかなんです 今住んでいるアパートに心が着く場合は
この荷物はどうやって運びます？これをどうやって片付けますかとかね
その荷物のことに心がいる
建物のことじゃないんです
あるいは新しい住居のこと
頭に入ってそれをばっかし頭であって
このタンスは新しい住居に持っていったっても意味がないとかね
これを処分しなくちゃいけないとかね
そういうふうに新しい住居について心が回転する
そのようにこの体の中で心がもう引っ越しようとすると
いわゆる心が体を捨てようとしちゃうと
もう体のことは全く無関心
その代わりにカンマ カンマに見て
ガティに見て ガティ ガティに見てと
つの対象どっちか現れちゃうんですね
カンマっていうのは何か業
行った行為を思い出す
あるいはその行為をする時
使った何か象徴になるものを思い浮かぶ
あるいは次に生まれる場所
心が次にどこに現れましょうかと思うと
その場所のことを思い浮かぶと
あるいはその場所を示される何か象徴が心に浮かぶ
ですから その種類の対象
どちらか心に最後に入る入るんですね
その瞬間で人が死んで次の場所に生まれちゃう
そこで最後の瞬間に思い出したことがいい行為であるならば
心は楽しくなるし 悪いことを思い出しちゃったら心は汚れて暗くなっちゃうし
まだ死んでないんです
死んでないんだけど 体には興味ないんだから何か思い浮かぶ
思い浮かんだものいいことであったら心が喜ぶ
悪いことだったら心がもう汚れてしまう
そこでこの死ぬ時まで心はずっとそのことばっかり気になっちゃうんですね
体が弱いんだから 新しい考え方は生まれようともしない
この体の中には興味ないんだからね
心に移ったあの 対象がずっと回転しちゃうんですね
で そこをなかなかサマタ
やめることもできないんです
で 体が元気だったらね
他のことを考えようとすることはできますけど
体が元気じゃないんだからね
で だから最後にそこまで対象には引っかかっちゃうんですね
強烈に で 元気な時でも私たちにも同じことは心の法則はいつでも死ぬ時でも死んでない時でも同じですからね
今でも私たちは何かちょっと強烈な対象が心に入ったら
ずっと心がそれに引っかかって
そればっかり回転しているでしょう
例えばこれから大変な用事があるとすると
この勉強よりはその用事の方が頭に入って
そればっかり考えたりしたりするし
で そういう風に心っていうのは何かこの強烈な対象が入ったら
ずっとそこを引っかかってね
回転したりするんですね
そういうのは心の普通の働きなんで
そういうのは治らないんですね
治すことできるのは このヴィパッサナー的な
この心を見る見方だけなんですね
で 癖をいろいろ直さなくちゃいけないと言えば
で ヴィパッサナーにしたっても長い間もう実行しないとそういう癖が治らない
ですから 死ぬ時はもうなんか心に入ってしまったら
もう強烈にそれはもう
なんて言いますか その過去のことかそれからのことなんですけど
この心にとってはすごい強烈に
それこの具体的に実現
現れてしまうんですね
幻覚 例えば過去に何かやったことが思い出しとする
で 思い出しちゃったら
普通我々何か思い出したら
もうそういうこと そんなに鮮明にその場面が現れるわけじゃないんですね
我々は何か過去のことを思い浮かぶと
死ぬ瞬間でそういうことじゃないんです
もう体と関係ないんだから
心が死ぬ瞬間で死ぬ瞬間でという死ぬ時はね
で 何か過去の業が過去やったことを思い浮かんだら
その場面が鮮明なところじゃなくて
全く具体的に今の瞬間でやっているような感じで心に移っちゃうんです
そういうふうなことで
この人間にはやっぱり輪廻するのことをね
転生することはもう全くお手上げ状態で避けられるものじゃないんです
ゲさせていない限りはまるっきり心のコントロールないんです
心っていうのはそういう風に人の意識で希望で
もうどうにもならないものなんですね
ですから 瞑想としたっても
丁寧に二種類分けてるんですね
サマタ瞑想というのは
心の流れをそのままいい方向へ
統一の方向へ流れるようにすると
ヴィパッサナーというのは別にそういうことではなくて
心そのものをコントロールするというかね
見てみて この管理すると
ですから サマーディ瞑想する人々にしても
心はいい方向に流れるんであって
コントロールできない
ヴィパッサナーの人 経験ある人にはまあすぐコントロールできる
その流れはすぐストップすることはできるんですね
たとえヴィパッサナーして
そういう癖がある人が死ぬ瞬間で何か悪い現象が見えたんだと
サティを入れる癖がついていちゃったら
もう何の問題もないんです
サティでそれを確認した瞬間で智慧
そこは智慧なんですね
現れてすぐ違う方向へ心が行ってしまうんです
そうでないと 人間の心っていうのは見たものに引かれちゃうんです
見たもの 聞いたものには引かれちゃうんです
で ここでこの三十四番目で言っているのは
この最後に最後の練習の時
心に映したものを心から離れないで
この具体的に現象化しているんだと
例えば死んだ人 死にかけている人が九十五歳で死にかけているんだと
練習の時になったと で
突然その人には十歳で自分の母親殴ったことを思い出したと
言ったら 自分が今は九十五歳ということはまるっきり関係ない
もう心は体と関係ないんだから
心にはそれを映しちゃいますから
その時のことを全くその通りに
その人に具体的に現象化になっちゃうんですね Manifestation
ですね 現象化するんです
その場面を それでもうずっと心がそればっかり考えたりする
だから悪いことを思い浮かぶか
いいことを思い浮かぶかっていうことは
それまた言いにくいことでわからないことで不確定である